honestly man like the more that i think
about this
the more
i feel like we might be totally [ __ ]
like it just feels like you know that
meme of the dog in the house and the
house is on fire and he's just smiling
through the beginning of the end this is
fine like if men don't kill themselves
they're exiting education and society
and family life at the highest rates
ever women are frantically pursuing
careers only to discover that they're
unable to find a partner that they're
attracted to and then jump on meds at 40
years old the highest uh percentage at
the highest group uh the huge meds are
between white women between 40 and 45
years old and then the people who want
kids can't find a partner that does as
well birth rates declining faith in the
leaders and the news organizations are
non-existent and everyone's just about
sufficiently sedated not to notice or
care that it's going on
that's a precise and accurate summary of
how the west has declined and will
collapse yes
[ __ ]
i know it's tr and do you know what's
worse right is that
the few that are in the generations that
are coming up now
are totally [ __ ] by leftist ideology
um the way that women young women view
men is evil it is purely as a
transaction
as in they are essentially prostitutes
every single one and they don't even
realize it and the young men what do you
mean you women as trophies you know
women are now just again they're not
people they don't view each other as
people the the thing a human being is a
three-dimensional thing it's it's got a
material component and then it's got an
emotional component and the spiritual
components you know like the the
metaphysics we ascribe to what is a
person and the thing that we consider
you know you're not just chris you're uh
you know you're not just the body of
chris you are you know a personality you
know i'm considerate of you when i'm
talking to you and things like this you
know when you when you message me on
facebook hey man how's it going you know
so
i don't just send you a link to my only
fans right and ask you to subscribe but
that's how a generation of women have
been trained by feminists to view men
in order not to be oppressed by the
patriarchy right and so these women i
think have been essentially made unable
to love men as people right they don't
really see them as people they they view
them as a kind of competit a competition
like
competitors on a playing field and the
young men don't know what to do and so
now they're just
following their base instincts of i
should try and have sex i should try and
see a woman naked you know and therefore
that's flattening a woman down to merely
her biological components now it's not
even romance you know
it's not about falling in love it's
about send nudes
it's
objectification from men to women and
commodification of
uh men from women like yeah is it was it
you that said um in the same way that
porn has skewed men's expectations of
women only fans have skewed women's
expectations of men
i've cited it by you uh even if it
wasn't so it may work because but
because i totally agree with that
statement i may have said that um
because it's it's awful how
only fan says
it's commodified being a girlfriend
right that's the thing so everyone
thinks oh you know you're just getting
nudes it's just like porn it's like it's
not just like
emotionally i've been watching a bunch
of youtube videos by women who do only
fans who explain what they're doing on
only fantastic i've never used them you
know god forbid my wife would kill me um
but
so it basically it seems like you're
sort of like an online artificial
girlfriend service you know and the sort
of romantic nudes that you'd send to one
another and sexy posts and stuff they
send to like you know 5 000 men or
however many years like right that's not
good is it you know that's that's
pretending to have an intimate
relationship with thousands of different
men and it's not surprising that there
have been recently a bunch of only fan
models who have been murdered by
subscribers no way yeah no no we
recently did a video in fact it should
be out on paul delicious already by the
time this goes up uh it's not out yet
though but um yeah we've got you know
three examples in the last week where
subscribers have murdered these people
and there was one guy who had gone to
florida stalked an oni fans model
murdered her and then written on like
the walls i shouldn't have come it's her
fault for making me love her or
something like that and stuff like this
and it's just like look this is
warped what it is to be in a romantic
and sexual relationship like pretending
that we can just commodify these things
and that's all a human being needs is
not true
both both people on both sides can
detach
their emotions from the situation
that the guy isn't going to feel
anything more than well he knows that
this is just messages he knows that this
is just work and the same as the
yeah precisely they can't switch that
off they can't switch that emotional
situation off but but for the the sort
of gen z woman
men are merely a mode of transaction
because they've been indoctrinated by
feminists in their schools and just in
the culture at large to view men as
being part of an oppressive structure
and they have to be on their guard
against men you know men are here to
take something from you men are
dangerous to women you know
you've got to
you've got to view them as a thing to
get money from well if they're the enemy
then defeating the enemy makes sense but
the other side of this is
i don't know
i i wonder what it teaches women
not only the women that do only fans but
even the women that know that other
women do only fans what does it teach
them about what their worth is we've
literally just said if you enter the
world and your primary source of value
is your looks or your sex appeal this is
a depreciating asset and you need to be
very very careful um this is the richest
i wouldn't like to guess there is a huge
swath of some of the richest people in
the uk and in america that are women
that are probably getting their money
directly from taking their clothes off
and sending photos to people that pay
them for it and that's what other women
are thinking as well so
by osmosis almost there's these role
models of women that are in a society
that says girls you can be a girl boss
too clap back don't settle for less be a
boss [ __ ] all of this stuff be a career
woman and also some of the most
successful career women that you know
are the ones who are using
base the lowest form of female value to
the world
as their way to climb this dominance
hierarchy like it's not good i don't
think it's good for women i don't think
it's good for men either it's terrible
for society in general you know it's
it's
again it it's it's teaching women that
men aren't
important and
unique things because like the the root
of every relationship every relationship
is unique right ev and
no one else can have that relationship
with you your relationship my
relationship to you my relationship to
my wife my relationship with my sons
they'll never have that relationship
ever again right you'll always have a
different relationship with someone else
and relationships are like
a chain you know like a rope you know
and if you don't if you don't like keep
it in good check if you don't you know
do the things that the other person
appreciates and if they don't
reciprocate and do the things you
appreciate then the relationship fades
and frays and ends up breaking you know
and then there could be other ways of
breaking it but like
it's something you have to nurture
something you have to take care of and
something that is what i think is the
the genuine content of the human
experience and i think that this is why
if you go back 100 years people were so
much poorer but they were not on
antidepressants they weren't all
depressed they weren't all sad because
they had their families they had their
friends they had their social life they
had a reason to live you know i've got
to go to over to mavis house and and
pick up her groceries for her you know
and stuff like this you feel good about
doing something good for someone else
maybe so probably make you a cup of tea
when you get there and you have a nice
little chat and things like this like
this these these relationships are the
genuine the what makes life worth living
you know ostracization used to be a
punishment you know and now people are
literally just ostracized on their
phones thinking god i hope twitter gives
me some likes today from who you don't
know you don't know any of these people
you know some men also are choosing to
ostracize themselves yeah consciously
you know that's what mgtow is what are
those guys in the apartment blocks in
china or japan there's a particular name
of all man yeah them plant man or
whatever it is um and
you know these are guys that are
consciously choosing to just exit
society in the way that we would
typically see it what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace